moi je voulais vous remercier parce que
ça fait pense dizaine d'années qu'on
voit à chaque fois pour l'émission je
crois je pense croisent et c'est vrai
que vous avez contribué à donner de
l'intérêt aussi au sujet miss france on
n'était pas toujours d'accord donc sais
pas
si cette jamais chez bright en tout cas
merci parce que vous avez toujours fait
preuve de on a d'une grande écoute on a
toujours une place chez vous donc merci
à vous toi tu as pris la décision de
quitter miss france tu n'es tu qui pas
gelé pas prise d'un coup l'a senti que
tu avais plus ta place c'est pas que
j'ai senti que j'avais plus ma place
j'ai senti que j'avais peut-être que
rien à apporter d'accord pour être
honnête parce que j'ai la rage j'ai vécu
les meilleures années moi je moi j'étais
avec des filles exceptionnel et
j'accepte dolphin tale delphine avait
bien sûr non mais bon si tu as eu deux
filles jeckyll et des années
correctionnel aux jo mais j'ai commencé
avec alexandra rosenfeld ah ouais avec
son ado rousset away et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui quand on regarde les
filles elles sont d animatrice radio de
talent des animatrices télé des médecins
moi je suis très fier de marée le revenu
je connais je connais david tout les
petits est en fait du coup pas fou il ya
plein de choses j'ai moi à titre
personnel j'ai réfléchi je me suis
qu'elles font les envies aujourd'hui
c'est pas ma société je savais qu'il
fallait que je parte qu'il faudrait que
je parte un jour l'évolution du concours
l'évolution de la société s'appelait pas
d'évolution du concours j'ai déjà émis
plein de réserve et benoît c'est quoi
ton ces derniers mois les dix nous là ce
soir c'est bon mais en fait tu y es tu
te sens tu feras là tu feras la soirée
en décembre à paris et je te sais j'ai
beaucoup souffert quand j'aime bien les
parties qu'elles coupent pas le cordon
ouais moi je trouve qu'il faut avoir un
respect je pars et je vais pas juger ce
que vont faire les prochaines équipes
sur l'évolution du règlement j'en ai
déjà parlé par exemple j'ai été miss
france j'ai dirigé miss france pendant
15 ans j'ai du mal à me demander comment
une miss france mère de famille avec des
enfants qui fait le tour du monde qui
est la glace à disposition pour tout le
monde d'avoir laissé ses enfants chez
elle elle va être obligée de faire des
choix économiquement alors peut-être que
demain il y aura une économie qui
permettra
de lui donner les moyens d'être
accompagné par sa famille ses enfants
qui je le sais donc tu penses les mères
de famille n'ont pas leur place dans le
concours je dis pas qu'elles n'ont pas
leur place je dis que le concours n'est
pas adapté l'agenda d'une miss france
n'est pas adapté à la vie d'une maman
bien sûr là j'en donne une mission ce
n'est pas adapté je sais moi j'ai été
miss france 3 en
colombie alors c'est cindy fabre oui
trente six ans qui prend la relève
c'était l'été miss cananéenne alors
cindy fabre elle était miss france 2005
alors c'est encore une fois si alex ya
six mois j'étais directeur général c'est
alexia qui devient président directeur
général voilà exactement et et elle va
être accompagnée de signes fabre jeu
sans four repris vendredi dans les
régions accompagner les délégations
accompagner les miss en fait donc
l'unifab chauffeur über des hits des
demis carré non mais c'est vrai nom
l'adorent signalé sympa dont cindy tu
étais content que tu sois là où moi je
n'ai pas élu en fait je la connais on
peut alors mais je trouve que
ce temps à [ __ ] non non non mais le
fait qu'elle soit miss ronde et j'allais
complètement légitime pour pour remplir
ce rôle je trouve ça très rose n'avait
pas repris de fines
alors après c'est le choix d'alexis à un
jeu encore une fois je pars moi j'ai pas
à juger des décisions et je les respecte
et je tâte aurait plus de films
oui oui c'est quelque chose de
vrai dans ton rôle à toi pas forcément
dans le rôle du business stimuler le
management c'est
après si cindy elle est fantastique donc
voilà elle va être proche des filles et
tous et ça c'est bien et c'est très
important pour elle il faut lui laisser
sa chance à la haye ce que si alexia
laroche-joubert n'était pas arrivé
est-ce que tu aurais continuer oui je
pense que manning est ici qu ici on
change beaucoup l'endroit avec nous
alors on enlève le site alexia n'arrive
pas
[Applaudissements]
avec je n'arrive pas est-ce que tu
restes un pas qui aurait peut-être
changer les choses parce que ce n'est
pas ma société si c'était devenu ma
société un jour peut-être rester j'avais
envie j'avais envie d'essayer de prendre
des parts dans ce jeu là oui j'ai essayé
parce que j'ai vécu miss france comme si
c'était un peu mon bébé enfin soit j'en
ai piqué à miss france miss france et
pains bio en fait on vit miss france ont
dormi chansons voyagent miss france je
suis en fait tout lui s'immisceront
c'était devenu ma société oui je serais
resté mais la serbie environ c'est
peut-être pour ça alors que ça c'était
parti non c'est pas pour que je vois le
truc tu as dû demander départ et ont dit
non à lui vont tirer
c'est de changer de vie non je n'ai pas
peur après 10 et 100 pour une raison
enfin si il ya eu ça j'ai bien les par
alexia sedif a prévu que johan est
choisi j'ai envie de faire autre chose
j'ai envie très timide je suis une femme
de bise neige et je sais qu'une femme de
19 ans a plein de choses à faire en
france et j'ai envie pour une j'ai pas
j'ai passé 17 ans à m'occuper des miss
france 17 ans à m'occuper des miss
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de m'occuper de
la france d'accord je trouve que on a
conçu une société qu'il faudrait qu'il
ferait couleur politique on a eu
énormément et j'ai fait 20 ans en
politique je suis et c'est pas en faire
non on a une crise du colis dont là moi
je suis je suis foncièrement patriotes
en fait j'aime mon pays je trouve que
depuis le coc vide on a des entreprises
y sont souffrance - allez bonne tu vois
les jets des champions de france ça fait
20 ans que j'entends que fermer
l'entreprise d'effacer les chars de
l'armée sont jamais fermées valorise et
le savoir faire français je trouve qu'on
a besoin sachant ça veut dire faire de
l' influence avec des jeunes femmes qui
ont été dits je me considère pas j'avais
une société d influence que je quitte
également je ne tiens pas bien mais
j'espère que tu quittes beaucoup de
choses et je me considère pas comme une
fin et l'influencé en revanche je sais
que j'ai de l' influence et aujourd'hui
on a plein de plein de pme plein
d'artisans qui ont de l'or entre les
mains mais qui n'ont pas l'expertisé
l'expérience des médias du business de
la digitalisation et j'ai envie c'est
vrai d'apporter mon aide à toutes ces
entreprises gilles pessah sylvie ces
magnifiques vous réussirez partout mais
très franchement si vous quittez miss
france c'est parce qu'à une
incompatibilité entre alexia laroche
joubert et vous y avait deux chefs pour
un poste il faut être honnête on y donne
deux caractères deux femmes des
autorités
avancer les choses et c'est elle qui a
gagné le combat avec tout le respect que
je dois comme elle est dans la société
elle a gagné le combat est donc vous
partez mais avec les honneurs mais vous
partez pour ça non je pars pas pour que
ça aussi lu
ça fait des années qu'on démarre à fait
désolé la montée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je partais pour ça je serais parti
peut-être plus vite est ce qu'elle est
elle est là depuis un an
les gens ont dit à ma part j'ai rabat
n'avait pas tout à fait un an et demi il
imitait les partis ou les négociations
ont été muets
non mais il faut aussi avoir conscience
d'une chose c'est que c'est un peu de la
folie j'ai 44 ans tbt plus belle que
jamais à la maison était plus belle que
jamais je jouis est en droit de se
retrouver chez me sens aujourd'hui je
trouve que on a le droit de prendre des
risques c'est pas que je m'ennuie chez
miss france mais j'ai envie de tuer
schyle j'ai envie de
gégé droit de me dire qu'aujourd'hui je
je je pense que je n'ai plus de choses à
apporter à miss france il faut laisser
la place à d'accord pas d'accord je suis
pas d'accord c'est une énorme erreur je
te le dis tu as fait ça fait dix ans
vous me dites que je suis amer supérieur
mais alors il a maintenant voulait que
je reste bien sûr je vais te dire c'est
comme quand ta meuf comment ça peut
faire c'est baliste tu as envie qu'elle
revienne est ce qu'on a c'est vrai vous
retenir est-ce que nice où il vivait
d'ailleurs alexis m'a proposé de faire
du consulting jusqu'à décembre j'ai
accepté de faire du bas mais bien sûr
tout cas veut pas se déchirer après
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on s'est dit les gars c'est jusqu'en
décembre ce n'est pas me faire chier à
prendre un an pour trouver quelqu'un
d'autre oui c'est vrai mais je te dis la
vérité aurait tout à y perdre entre à
terme après vous là on décèle alex a
annoncé que ce serait sinon c'est nier
c'est cindy en fait à lille par messi du
rituel est sympa l'a vu s'affirmer wifi
ni tora bora
vient pas de moi j'espérais nous oui on
parle de vision très différente avec
alexia et c'est clair parce que le clash
il est là il ya fin la limite d'âge à 25
quand est ce que vous êtes d'accord où
vous êtes contre s'il n'ya plus des
ménages aujourd'hui il a plu du tout à
coeur alors les femmes arrière vous a
senti pas très chaude par rapport à la
vie d'une femme active qui est un trait
alors qu'eux ils sont plutôt d'accord
quand tu pars d'une société respecte
l'avenir je ne veux pas aujourd'hui je
veux m'imposer un devoir de réserve ce
qui va se passer je m'en vais j'ai fait
mes cartons tout alors je suis parti me
sens d'accord pour les femmes
transgenres je ne m'exprimerai pas sur
le règlement miss france bac en clair
japon alors sinon je serais prêt à
envisager un mais il ya plein de choses
envisagés il ya la télé réalité aussi 12
mois n'est pas sur un
référé s'entendent plus alors non mais
geneviève était d'une nouvelle ou pas
j'ai des nouvelles elle fêtait son
anniversaire hier elle a fait un
magnifique communiqué tresses et
j'embrasse exactement est ce qu'on l'a
alors je la regarde regarde parce que
lorsqu'on a le communiqué de presse vous
l'avez pas dit non mais ils sont cons
comme des pendules
enfin communiqué de presse geneviève et
joliette a laissé un petit message oui
non mais finalement
vrai tu vois le communiqué près c'est
avec une certaine émotion que j'ai
appris avec quand même il est long
ça fait le départ il se résigne de la
direction malgré nos désaccords jeunes
expriment tous mes voeux de succès dans
la poursuite de sa carrière elle dispose
de nombreuses ressources et suis
certaine qu'elle rebondira avec talent
je garde en mémoire les bons moments de
son année de francs de son année 2002 et
2003 vous 2012 ouais ouais c'est dix ans
différents sa voix de cindy fabre une
dmz ex-miss france couronné en 2005
succède est une excellente nouvelle je
lui adresse mes sincères félicitations
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta et à la fin elle
mais geneviève de fontenay très heureuse
quand geneviève est fâché le single
fâché non c'est vrai il faudrait
landévant vie de famille et
je n'embrasse pas ce que l'on savait on
n'a pas toujours été titulaire avec
geneviève ouais mais j'ai très touché
par ce communiqué alors elle à el alto
laisse un petit message vocal est ce
qu'on laisse les pentes enneigées ont
fait l'histoire de quelque chose qui
mérite pas ça enfin quand même c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose ait des choses
plus importantes que ça en ce moment ça
use même l'importance qu'elle mérite
porte toute façon s'il dit elle a pas eu
le temps que j'ai passé mois so so et
miss 1 parce que moi je suis là quand
même depuis 1947 c'est pas la peine
qu'on se comprend parce qu'il n'y a rien
de comparable je pense hermois pas à pas
nulle part dans la rue dans les traduire
par tout le monde barrette et quand elle
est à côté de moi s'il n'y a personne
lui demandait rien elle m'a pris 40 ans
de ma vie tu es dit elle elle a fait
venir les 30 miss france en disant que
j'étais centenaire non mais je savais
pas digéré
n'a pas digéré les maillots deux pièces
non plus et je je quand je regarde
tu
avais pas entendu le maïs et
les photos franchement je me dis que
l'un des bilans c'est la modernité du
mauvais sort est sylvie je te le dis tu
as été exceptionnel moi quand j'ai
appris la nouvelle j'étais hyper v lire
je te le dis parce que je pense que sans
toile au concours ça ça tiendra pas
c'était et était la gardienne du temple
des règles concours miss france et s'il
n'y a pas quelqu'un qui tient les rênes
qui donne pas les règles et qui dit pas
qui est ici n'est pas derrière les
milices et qui tient pas une poigne et
je vois bien c'est une catastrophe et
puis ne vous dit pas aussi à un moment
donné que l'on sait peut-être jours à
porter ça fait souvent le cas de la
directrice de l'ap hm sympa parce que je
suis toujours ce que j'ai dit aux filles
je suis toujours à vous appeler en
faisant attention les filles penser à 6
penser à ça j'en ai un peu marre non que
j'aie envie vous découvriez autrement je
suis je suis je suis comme tout le monde
je suis pas directrice dans ma vie tous
les matins tous les soirs et si on vient
d'un peu de légères et je voudrais dire
bien sylvie elle est très très drôle
dans la vie même si on est très drôle a
les traits de kedar cas et elle et elle
est très sympa et c'est vrai que elle a
ce côté tout le monde croit qu'elle est
très stricte alors que t'arrêtes pas
déconner mais parce que c'était moins la
fonction entre les deux choix stricte
d'ailleurs on nous faisait venir
uniquement pour nous pour parler d'un
truc super sérieux et toujours stricte
et la lecture que je me défende général
avocate de france quelques pas toujours
être avec toi donc fort boyard c'était
la meilleure miss ah ouais merci très
bonnes interventions sur elle
justement justement sur les miss
jeux jeux de bonnes questions tu as
vraiment j'aime beaucoup ton émission
sur les régions sont en voyage à web a
très bien réagi et bien la seule qui la
regardent
pas peur nous misons je te pose des
questions il ya des missiles vont
s'afficher tu dois me dire qu'ils
étaient la miss la miss préférée de
toutes les miss que tu as eu 6 h place
et c'est alors à toi on s'en fout
j'attire items bien diane ccd le film
n'en sert d'ariane c'est camille sée
kaminski dis la vérité je peux plus me
direz-vous à légiférer si alors promis
les gens du monde voilà plus bordélique
la pampa je m'attendais plus à jeter ne
sais tu peux pas alors elles m'appellent
maman c'est toujours je grogne mais ce
qui si on me demande qui dans tes
enfants ont préféré tu peux pas en
france
mais en fait c'est chez moi je les aime
toutes pour l'heure
sa cale pas le moins aimé alors
actuellement et mélanie ce que toi moi
et mes ya là bien lui disait qu'elle
flemme de passer un an
rené l'année seulement l'année là non je
peux te dire la plus en retard je m'en
fous de rang desquels moi j'ai loupé
savoir la vie cela présente à redire y
aura de l'émotion on s'en fout et évasif
oui au moins le coup de coeur soit là
pour laquelle à coups de coeur un break
un braqueur d'ivoire à fréha les dunes
où j'adore 10 à 12 heures camille
ggl si tu vas pendant que j'étais celle
à la rigueur la plus grande souffrance
pour moi voilà bah oui l'année de
valérie bègue valérie bègue j'ai
beaucoup souffert et une vallée mal
manger trop dourthe non mais
j'ai défendu j'ai beaucoup défendu
valérie j'aime bien rouler la destituer
j'ai défendu valérie j'essayais de faire
excuser une erreur de jeunesse j'avais
jeune garde un côté
c'était une année pour moi très
difficile je sais que je crois que j'ai
un petit faible pour diane je peux pas
dire la vérité je le sais j'aime bien
salée france je serais d'avis ou deux
pourquoi du chroniqueur tu préfères mais
ça c'est le seul qui a une émission
radio tu sais tu vois tu vois ce tour
des émissions le plus de fois tu vois ce
qui les ont perdus regarder
que ce soit camille qui me succède c'est
vrai qu'à me sers c'est vrai que j'avais
fait des propositions mais pas par
préférence parce que il me semblait
qu'il était bien d'avoir une jeune femme
proche des gens qui aiment les régions
après camille elle est là d'autres est
la page a plein d'autres projets encore
une fois je respecte la décision
annexant c'est pas moi c'est un mystère
pour moi c'est c'est je pense elle fait
partie des trois plus belles miss aller
toute l'histoire donc je suis façon je
la trouve assez elle est très
sympathique en sait quelque chose ouais
ça fait partie des trois plus belles
miss de de l'histoire c'est que les deux
autres
filets des investissements et à dia le
tuer beaucoup de gens ne retiennent
j'aime beaucoup delphi dalian qui
travaillent à jean radio bédié
aujourd'hui reste qu'un petit amoureux
qui s'appelle donne à
voir si les pleurs c'était un message
fort diane c'est vrai pas censés se
retrouver pour l'europe
sylvie est ce que tu vas continuer à
faire de la télé juste pour savoir un
oui je vais continuer à faire de la
dilce que j'adore ça ou ça
bah je me considère un peu de la famille
de tf1 mais comme beaucoup de
changements en ce moment d'accord ce qui
est important c'est travailler avec une
équipe qu'on aime d'accord mais en tout
cas tu serais très très bonne animatrice
franchement proposé mais je sais pas
mais moi je considère un foot c'est jean
pierre foucault c'est mon papa de la
télé il m'a tout appris c'est pour ça
que c'était important pour moi d'être à
ses côtés cette année parce que mes mais
c'est vrai que fera ses côtés d'alain
prochain cette année en effet enregistré
avec la très bien votre regardera sylvie
en tout cas tu vas nous manquer tu
reviens nous voir quand tu veux merci
paul on t'aime tu été formidable merci
merci